this is how i shoot ads
hey everyone i'm john coogan this video
is going to be a little bit different
from my usual content because it's
entirely focused on my actual job
i've been an entrepreneur for the past
decade and that title can mean a lot of
things
at soylent i was co-founder and cto so
my primary focus was on building the
e-commerce website where we sold our
products
i also helped out with finance legal hr
and marketing
but most of my time was spent managing a
team of software developers and
designers
to help scale our online sales after
five years spent building soylent i
started a new company focused on putting
an
end to cigarettes we named this company
lucy
after the loose cigarettes that some
smokers buy and refer to as
lucy's we all kind of shuffled positions
this time around
david rental who was the chief marketing
officer at soylent
stepped into the ceo role at lucy since
it was really his idea for the company
to begin with
and sami hamduce who was our vp of
research at soylent
stepped into the coo role at lucy
we knew that marketing was going to be
really important since smokers are
fiercely loyal to their cigarette brands
and we weren't going to need to build as
much custom software as we did at
soylent
because shopify had gotten significantly
more capable in the last few years
so i became the chief marketing officer
and have been working on figuring out
how to get smokers to trade cigarettes
for our nicotine gums and lozenges ever
since
as cmo i spend most of my time thinking
about how to grow the company
i work on finding ways to improve our
website spend our advertising dollars
more effectively
and making new creative assets to help
promote our products
and that's what i'm going to cover today
we need some new ads and i'm going to
try and shoot them in-house with the
help of our creative director julio
miles
who was also the creative director at
soylent as you can see we really like
the team that we built there
now to give a bit of perspective we
could afford to pay an agency to shoot
ads for us
and we have in the past at soylent we
paid a few thousand dollars to a small
team in la to shoot our crowdfunding
video
and it came out so poorly that our
investors later told us
that they actually thought we made it
bad intentionally
to make fun of kickstarter videos later
when we raised our series a
we spent over a hundred thousand dollars
on a professional shoot where we lit a
plane
on fire at lucy we've tried to take more
of a middle of the road approach
spending a few hundred dollars with
small creators and then doing the
occasional bigger shoot with agencies
that charge around 10k
we're fortunate enough to have raised
about 15 million dollars in funding
so we could probably afford to pay
agencies all the time
but this is less about saving money and
more about the learning process
as i mentioned in my last video my
favorite thing about startups is that
they are amazing learning environments
shooting this ad myself will save my
company money but it will also help me
learn
what goes into making a great ad so that
the next time i hire someone to shoot
new creative for me
i can properly assess their abilities
and understand the trade-offs involved
in what they do
it's very hard to manage someone if you
don't have an appreciation for their
craft
this is really true for programmers and
it's a big reason why there is so much
focus on learning to code
if you're going to start a tech company
even though you might not be programming
regularly if the company is successful
you'll need to understand code in order
to run the company effectively
paul graham had a great tweet about this
he said
if you want to start a startup it's good
to know about multiple
unrelated things startups often depend
on four or five different kinds of
knowledge
and it's great if they can all be found
in just two founders
i think that lucy's success depends on
knowledge of programming
biochemistry law sales and video
production
so this is how i'm developing knowledge
around video production
before we turned on any cameras julio
and i worked through
our goals for this project we agreed
that we wanted to make lucy look
approachable to smokers and stay away
from the clinical themes usually seen in
pharmaceutical ads
we also only want to appeal to adults
since our products are sold to people
over the age of 21.
with that in mind julio mapped out a few
storylines that could resonate with our
target audience
the unboxing experience which emphasizes
how convenient it is to get our products
delivered to your door
instead of needing to run out for
cigarettes which you can't buy online
the working experience where lucy can
help you skip those smoke breaks that
take you away from what you're working
on
and the driving experience so you can
keep your car smelling fresh
here's us shooting the unboxing
experience we started with a shot of the
package arriving
staged in my living room with some junk
mail behind it to make it look like a
receiving area
then we moved to my coffee table to show
julio opening the package
and trying the product i tried to get
some cool motion with the camera
so that the shots would look more
visually dynamic and could be cut
together in interesting ways during the
edit
i'm using a sony a7s3 here with a 24
millimeter lens
it's a really nice camera and it isn't
cheap but you can totally achieve
similar results with a phone if you're
just starting out
never let gear hold you back i shot
everything in 120 frames per second
so i would have the ability to slow
things down in post to highlight
certain beats within each shot some of
the camera moves were pretty tricky to
line up with julio's movements
so we had to do about 10 takes for each
shot before we got something that we
liked i shot everything handheld
but because it's all in slow motion
there isn't too much camera shake here's
the raw footage before any of the
editing
it looks pretty good by itself but we
can spice it up a lot by adding some
speed ramping
i edit everything in adobe premiere pro
but you can do all of this stuff in
pretty much any editing software
just start by looking up tutorials on
youtube that's honestly what i did
so after ramping the speed so each clip
is fast at the start and the end
but slow in the middle here's what i had
not bad but transitions between clips
will help tie everything together
so i grabbed a pack of transitions off
of envato and drop the effects on each
cut in the timeline
lastly i added a subtle color grade just
to boost the colors a bit and add a
vignette to focus the viewer's eye
towards the center of the frame
then i added a piece of stock music from
epidemic sound and exported the video
here's how the final edit turned out
[Music]
so my takeaway here would i run this at
the super bowl
probably not but is it worth testing
online definitely
more importantly i'm getting more
comfortable shooting this type of
content
and feel like i have a better
understanding of what goes into making
great video ads
this whole shoot was heavily inspired by
daniel schiffer and other youtubers who
make amazing ads on really tight budgets
i can only learn so much by watching
those videos though at a certain point i
need to just
try some things for myself and get a
feel for it we shot for about five hours
and i only showed you the final version
of one of the ads
we filmed four other scenes and are
going to work on editing those together
over the next week
i already have a bunch of ideas for how
i can improve these projects in the
future
and really can't wait for the next shoot
it's so fun to learn a new skill
even if the beginning process is super
rough and everything is just terrible
for a while
hopefully this video is helpful to
anyone who needs to make ads for their
startup
even if i was selling a software product
i would still probably learn how to make
great video content to help promote it
but let me know what you think in the
comments below do you like this type of
video
i still plan on doing more deep dives on
tech topics
but i figured that i could mix in some
of my real world experiences for variety
i have a bunch of videos planned for
this year so please consider subscribing
to the channel
and as always thanks for watching